por primera vez en la historia de la
humanidad vamos a convertir a combatir
este bello planeta
con alguien más inteligente que nosotros
es más con alguien que poco a poco se va
a convertir en alguien más inteligente
que todos nosotros juntos y no no estoy
hablando de donald trump
- de peña
estoy hablando de la inteligencia
artificial nos tocó a nosotros en esta
generación ser los testigos de como el
sueño de la inteligencia artificial
finalmente se hace realidad hoy las
computadoras finalmente pueden pensar
por ellas mismas
esto va a evolucionar la evolución del
ser humano en los próximos años de
manera impresionante es más esta
evolución va a ser más que exponencial
que es la evolución que nos ha tocado en
los últimos años y de la cual vamos a
platicar nos va a tocar ver unos cambios
increíbles y si todo sale bien nos va a
tocar ver los cambios positivos en
nuestras vidas y en la gente y en la
vida de la gente que amamos
surgen muchas preguntas la primera que
me surge es si nosotros estamos
creciendo en la ética a la par de lo que
estamos creciendo en la tecnología
porque si una de estas se despega puede
haber hechos terribles yo creo que sí yo
creo que si en los últimos años no
hubiéramos crecido en la ética y en la
compasión al mismo tiempo que ya
crecimos en la tecnología ya no
estaríamos aquí ya habríamos destruido
el planeta porque hoy tenemos las
herramientas para hacerlo yo sí creo que
la tecnología hasta ahora ha estado en
manos de gente buena y de gente positiva
salvo algunas excepciones en la historia
entonces para mí la pregunta relevante
es dado que ahora con la tecnología y
las computadoras no solamente van a
correr programas no solamente van a
contestar órdenes no solamente van a
correr rutinas y probar y quizá mejorar
y probar otra vez sino a partir de ya
están pensando por ellas mismas están
creando lenguajes están creando
soluciones están creando problemas
para mí la pregunta trascendente es si
vamos a poder nosotros como especie
transferir y enseñarlas ahora que se
puede y que todavía nos enseñan ellas
mismas a muchas cosas si vamos a poder
ser capaces de transmitir precisamente
esa compasión y esa ética que nos ha
mantenido creciendo como seres humanos y
no solamente creciendo desde la
perspectiva tecnología y herramientas
como llegamos aquí
esto lógicamente no sucedió de un día
para otro el hecho de que en los últimos
años haya sucedido y en los próximos
vaya a suceder con una velocidad
impresionante no significa que esto no
vaya sucediendo prácticamente desde que
el ser humano está en la tierra y ahí
hay un debate interesante porque pues
desde cuando empezamos como especie a
inventar ya utilizar tecnología pues
puede ser desde nuestros ancestros y es
más está probado que antes del homo
sapiens ya había herramientas y ya los
seres humanos utilizamos herramientas y
tecnología vamos a explorar un poquito
el ser humano tiene varias capacidades
únicas no tantas pero tiene algunas que
nos distinguen de todas las demás
especies de las especies conocidas
una de ellas y una de las más
importantes que somos capaces de adaptar
nuestro entorno y utilizar todo lo que
existe a nuestro alcance para facilitar
la vida en realidad para hacernos la
vida más eficiente para hacer las cosas
más rápido hacer las cosas más fáciles y
para utilizar nuestro tiempo en cosas
más productivas esta es una capacidad
que nosotros hemos desarrollado mucho
pero que no es única de los seres
humanos por ejemplo pues un castor puede
utilizar la madera que tiene a su
alcance para cambiar el hábitat en el
que vive y en este caso hacer una
pequeña empresa un gordo y lograr que la
naturaleza funcione a su favor
los seres humanos así fuimos
descubriendo cómo utilizar las cosas que
tenemos a nuestro alrededor y las fuimos
mezclando las fuimos fusionando y las
fuimos perfeccionando para de nuevo para
hacernos la vida más fácil
sin embargo hacia allá los pájaros igual
por ejemplo que utilizan la naturaleza
en este caso para hacer sus casas sea no
solamente para hacer su trabajo más
fácil sino para hacer el hábitat en
donde nacen sus sus pollitos sus
pajaritos
lo que sí nos distingue es la capacidad
de transmitir de una generación a otra
lo que vamos conociendo lo que vamos
entendiendo y la manera en que vamos
solucionando los problemas pónganse a
pensar la cantidad de horas hombre que
hay en un lugar como el que estamos hoy
en una realidad como la que estamos hoy
la cantidad de personas la cantidad de
pensamiento alcance de trabajo que tuvo
que haber para que yo pueda utilizar
esto para cambiar algo en una pantalla
que existan luces que existan una
alfombra a la que hay que enderezar un
poquito que exista una pantalla que
existan ustedes sentados en unas sillas
que haya un proyector aquí estamos
hablando de millones de horas millones
estamos construyendo como dicen por ahí
en encima del de los hombros de los
gigantes y eso solamente es posible
porque somos la única especie que es
capaz de transferir de generación a
generación ese conocimiento y poder
mejorar las cosas entonces cada vez
existe una nueva
personas pensando en un problema en el
que millones de personas ya pensar no
anteriormente está sumando a este equipo
humanidad y está contribuyendo al
desarrollo
no solamente podemos transmitir podemos
hacer otra cosa que solamente podemos
ser nosotros podemos anticipar el futuro
podemos imaginarlo podemos plantearnos
podemos modelar los escenarios podemos
decir oye qué tal si oye qué pasaría si
bien y en base a eso podemos actuar
somos la única especie que razona a base
de proyectar al futuro que puede diseñar
soluciones para diferentes escenarios y
sobre todo que puede tomar una decisión
y actuar en consecuencia y que si se
equivoca puede regresar al análisis
inicial puede tomar otro escenario de
solución y puede utilizar y eso es
fascinante hasta ahorita somos los
únicos
el crear es lo más natural que existe en
el ser humano así que cuando discutimos
y hemos creado cosas antinaturales hay
que tener mucho cuidado porque no
sacamos ningún recurso que no estuviera
en la naturaleza lo único que hicimos es
basado en nuestra naturaleza humana le
dimos forma y lo utilizamos de manera
distinta lo que quiero decir aquí es que
la tecnología es absolutamente natural
los últimos 50 años y los próximos 50 o
los próximos 10 y lo que sea los
próximos 3 etc
vamos a ver unos avances espectaculares
a nosotros ya nos tocó a nosotros tocó
el brinco del análogo la digital en casi
todas las áreas humanas que es
espectacular muchos de nosotros llegamos
a marcar un teléfono de disco y ahora
tenemos el smartphone en nuestras manos
muchos de nosotros llegamos a escribir
las cartas y mandarlas en un correo
ahora escribió ni me dio muchos de
nosotros hablábamos por un cable
telefónico y ahora hablamos por una
interfase que convierte nuestra voz en
unos y ceros la manda del otro lado del
planeta y hay otra interfase que la
convierte otra vez en voz nos tocaron
cambios increíbles nada más que ya nos
ya se nos hace común ya el nuevo iphone
ya es el la evolución del anterior
cuando por ejemplo nuevo tiene dos o
tres tecnologías que los seres humanos
nunca habíamos utilizado de manera
masiva ya nos acostumbramos nada es que
vienen los brincos tan fuertes que
todavía nos van a mover el tapete no se
preocupen que como seres humanos no
hemos perdido la capacidad de asombro se
los prometo
en los últimos 50 años la tecnología ya
no se desarrolló de manera lineal la
manera lineal del desarrollo tecnológico
es prácticamente como el desarrollo
celular
se genera uno los generan dos y luego se
generan dos etcétera esa generación
celular y esa generación tecnológica en
los últimos años a través de la
invención del microchip particularmente
de las computadoras se exponen zio que
significa empezó a crecer de manera
exponencial ya no eran uno y luego dos y
luego tres y luego dos por dos etcétera
sino que eran 1 2 4 8 16 32 etcétera hay
una ley que sirvió sesión que se llama
gordon moore que fue el fundador de
intel que explica esto y lo explica la
siguiente manera cada microchip nuevo se
elabora con herramientas y con
tecnología en las cuales los microchips
de la generación anterior están actuando
dado que estos son más avanzados que los
anteriores el próximo va a ser
exponencialmente mejor y así los últimos
50 años la tecnología se ha ido
multiplicando de manera exponencial
hasta ahora en los próximos años ya no
va a ser exponencial porque ya no
depende de una restricción física en
este caso del microchip de prácticamente
un material y un centímetro milímetro
cuadrado ahora depende de la capacidad
de pensamiento y la capa
el pensamiento sumada y ahora ya no está
limitada por el pensamiento humano
porque a partir de algunos años atrás
pero sobre todo estos años por venir las
cosas van a ser inventadas y creadas de
cero por entidades no humanas
no es casualidad que el nintendo hubiera
progresado de 16 bits a 32 a 64 128 el
próximo nintendo probablemente sea el 4
mil 717 sea los brincos que ustedes y
que nosotros vamos a empezar a ver como
les decía no son ni lineales ni
exponenciales van a ser abruptos fíjense
lo que está pasando por ejemplo en el
sector financiero hay venían a la
tecnología y estaban los cajeros y luego
estaban los pagos móviles y todo mundo
pensábamos que digamos que seguía y de
repente un cuate inventa un sistema
completamente alternativo al mundo real
de intercambio de bienes y servicios por
dinero y crea el famoso blog single
bitcoin por primera vez un sistema que
hasta ahorita todavía es irrompible y
que es completamente transparente para
toda la humanidad nadie lo hubiera
pensado mucho de eso se creó a través de
algoritmos que se crean los solitos que
se crearon dándole una instrucción a la
computadora de encuentra una solución a
este problema que parece que existe la
computadora esa en particular que generó
el problema dijo el programa no es ese
el problema es este y encontró la
solución
este tema de soluciones y problemas está
sofía no sé si vieron ella es sofía para
los ortodoxos de ella esté todavía a mí
me cuesta trabajo si es algo a alguien
no la tema de la tecnología
ella es sofía ella es uno de los
primeros robots que no solamente tienen
independencia absoluta de cualquier tipo
de programación sino que tiene una
interfase impresionante de gestos
entonces la interacción con con sofía es
muy sorprendente muy muy importante a
ella le acaban de dar la nacionalidad de
arabia saudita el año pasado yo para una
semana pasada y si es un tema de
publicidad todavía de novedad pero
acuérdense de mí y de esa plática en el
futuro ya no vamos a estar hablando
solamente con personas vamos estar
hablando con el auto que te viene a
recoger con tu asistente electrónica que
te soluciona tu agenda con el área
aunque te llevo de un lado a otro o con
sofía de la cual te enamoraste y con la
cual anda saliendo
hemos ido acercando las tecnologías a
nosotros cada vez más existe un hambre
del ser humano de tener la tecnología
más cerca ya no nos basta con tener el
teléfono aquí con la onpe ya queremos
ahora los huevos por si no estos los
festivales
pero en el futuro estamos ya pensando en
vamos a tragarnos la tecnología vamos a
implantar en nuestro cuerpo porque ya no
nos va a convenir no hacerlo a poco
ustedes nos encantaría no tener que
recargar su celular y no tener que
cargar y de repente hacer así allá sea
una llamada o ser así y obtener un mapa
ya hay pruebas hay pruebas como ésta
aparte pero de regreso al hardware
aparte de que nos estamos acercando cada
vez más la tecnología a nosotros con
claves dispositivos más potentes más
pequeños y más adaptados a nuestros
cuerpos estamos generando una cantidad
de información impresionante en las
redes sociales y en las redes digitales
en el medio digital todo lo que ustedes
y yo hacemos en el mundo digital se
graba todo lo que ustedes y yo hacemos
se analiza todo todas las llamadas que
hacen de su iphone todas las llamadas
que hacen en skype todos los mensajes
que van de whatsapp las cosas buenas y
las cosas no tan buenas todas las
discusiones que tienen con la novia con
el novio todo todo se está guardando por
eso ustedes ven a las compañías grande
tecnología comprando de manera voraz
capacidad de almacenamiento y de
y de manejo de datos porque todo se está
almacenando hoy establecimos como
humanidad un contrato social con estas
empresas y les dijimos llévate mi
privacidad llévate mis datos llévate la
interacción con mis amigos llévate las
fotos de mi comida está bien a escoger
lo que quieras con ella
devuélveme publicidad más relevante más
amigos más likes más ego y existe ese
intercambio de valor hasta ahorita
funciona nadie se ha quejado tan fuerte
de facebook como para que como humanidad
decidamos dejarlo probablemente en la
siguiente evolución hay otra herramienta
que nos guste más y haga está obsoleta
pero pues a esta vista parece que no hoy
y por ejemplo facebook y le lleva sus
años lo mismo twitter y demás nada más
para darles una referencia facebook
solamente analiza hoy el 3 por ciento de
la información que tienen nosotros y con
eso genera 56 billones de dólares en
venta de publicidad al año
imagínense el poder de cada porcentaje
más y aparte no sabes un porcentaje más
sino que la cámara de información va
creciendo
cuando este análisis de facebook llevan
al 9 por ciento que es más allí por
noviembre 17 a las 4 30 de la tarde del
ellos van a poder hacer algo que nos va
a parecer bien interesante al principio
porque luego nos va a parecer que era
increíble que no lo hacíamos antes
facebook y amazon están trabajando en un
proyecto que se llama producto de
consumo predictivo nos vamos a asociar a
esta red y nos va a llegar los productos
a nuestra casa en una caja y simplemente
vamos a consumir utielanos tocar bar
porque seguramente ya lo queríamos hoy
la información y de análisis puede
predecir una manera mucho más certera lo
que queremos y necesitamos que nosotros
mismos eso es increíble
si no me creen tienes ustedes utilizan
spotify varios que crean spotify es un
sistema de consumo predictivo que aparte
es club tú no vales pagas y él te manda
la música que necesitas así nos va a
pasar con todas las categorías
algo que está sucediendo que también
está pasando por primera vez en la
humanidad es todo esto afortunadamente
se está usando para muchas cosas muy
buenas quizá para algunas no muy buenas
también pero esas no no las conocemos
pero para la cosa que creo yo mejor que
se está utilizando es para entender
ahora si lo más íntimo que tenemos los
seres humanos y que nos caracteriza
también y que nos distingue a los unos a
los otros que es nuestras emociones
nuestro bagaje emocional por primera vez
dada la cantidad de dispositivos y de
información y de capacidad de
administración de esta información por
primera vez estamos empezando a
realmente entender las emociones humanas
y eso sí es fascinante porque las
emociones marcan todas nuestras
decisiones y no sólo eso marcan la
manera en la que vemos el mundo al
entender estas emociones vamos a poder
modelar las al poder modelar las vamos a
poder influir las al poder influir las
vamos a poder cambiarlas y en eso
estamos trabajando varios de nosotros
déjenme les platico
imagínense poder conocer con detalle qué
es lo que es lo que nos produce alegría
y por qué nos produce alegría estar con
las personas y que la tecnología nos
ayude a entender cuanto más o cuánto
menos deberíamos estar con una persona
con otra para ser más felices
que nos ayude a entender nuestros miedos
nuestras tristezas
nuestra frustración y no sólo la nuestra
que nos permita entender aquella de las
personas que amamos que nos ayuda a
entender superar y mejorar el proceso de
duelo el proceso de tristeza
la expresión
imagínense ser capaces como como raza
humana de atender el problema
psicológico número uno que tenemos y que
hemos tenido en toda la historia es esa
depresión esa falta de sentido esa falta
de dirección esa falta de ritmo
imagínense poder entender mejorar
modificar e incrementar nuestros sueños
y nuestros anhelos salir de aquí común
con una recarga de eso que no solamente
viene de nuestro poder propio de
producir emociones positivas sino que
tuviera una ayuda
imagínense que pudiéramos por ejemplo
identificar nuestras verdaderas
emociones muchas veces sabemos lo que
estamos sintiendo imagínense que
pudiéramos identificar las verdaderas
emociones de los demás que pudiéramos
leer un poquito mejor a la pareja o al
hijo a la suegra y que podamos entender
realmente qué es lo que está sucediendo
bueno pues dejen de imaginarse porque
esto ya está sucediendo
existe tecnología que nos permite
filtrar esta información que nos permite
entender que nos permite crear la que
nos permite administrar la que nos
permite modelar la y proyectarla
existe tecnología por ejemplo es una
empresa hermana que está leyendo
actualmente 7 millones de caras todos
los días a través de diferentes
dispositivos por ejemplo si ustedes
hacen una llamada por facetime de apple
apple tiene una licencia con ellos y le
está pasando todas las caras que hacemos
pero no solamente las caras le pasa
también el sonido entonces están ellos
correlacionando cuándo y por qué ponemos
una cara de cierta expresión cuando
estamos en una conversación imagínese
por ejemplo un modelo predictivo que tú
estés en una llamada con alguien y tú
quieras empujar una agenda por ejemplo
de que se enoje o que te dé un permiso y
que la herramienta prácticamente te diga
pues mira basado en la cara y lo que
estoy escuchando no se lo plantees
ahorita la antesala después
otra empresa hermana en motive tiene hoy
un dispositivo que se puede cargar todo
el día y que puede medir un set de 400
emociones imagínese lo poderoso que va a
ser empezar a hacer pruebas de cosas
súper trascendentes por ejemplo cómo fue
la experiencia de un niño en la escuela
durante la mañana o cuál fue la reacción
de unas personas a ver una película le
escuchaban la charla y empezar a
correlacionar y de nuevo empezamos a
modelar empezamos a hacer soluciones
empezamos a cambiar las cosas vamos a
tener unas cosas impresionantes nada más
pónganse a pensar en esto actualmente
vivimos con productos y servicios que
fueron modelados y creados con métodos
de investigación bastante arcaicos con
observación con encuestas con
diferencias estadísticas ahora no ahora
van a ser creados basados en nuestro
propio pensamiento nuestras propias
emociones de nuestro propio
comportamiento ya no en lo que le
decimos son encuestados ahora que vienen
las elecciones le conectamos alguien
éste le preguntamos por qué va a votar y
en unos va poder mentir estamos
empezando en méxico un movimiento y una
empresa para poder entender las
emociones a nivel familiar
creemos que es ahí donde podemos tener
más impacto y donde si nosotros
participamos junto con ustedes podríamos
utilizar la tecnología para algo súper
positivo nosotros creemos que para
cambiar al mundo podemos cambiar a esas
relaciones familiares por lo menos
empezar a entenderlas mejor y empezar le
dar herramientas tanto a los hijos como
a los padres para poder a mejor hora de
mejorar las experiencias el contenido y
las experiencias son a uno
con nuestros hijos en mi caso o con
nuestros padres parece que esto funciona
de dos vías
hoy que estamos viendo a nuestro hombre
del futuro yo les presenté un cachito
pero de esta información hay muchísimo
más les quiero pedir un par de cosas
primero que no se espante está en buenas
manos y ustedes son también parte de eso
entonces está en buenas manos de ustedes
les quiero invitar a un par de cosas los
primeros que se orienten un poquito en
su realidad en sus sueños en sus
negocios en sus proyectos qué va qué
papel va a jugar la inteligencia
artificial y cómo la pueden utilizar de
manera positiva
que ustedes visualicen y ustedes se vean
y se pregunten a ustedes mismos bueno yo
que yo soy una persona que simplemente
va a dar información y que va a recibir
productos servicios mejores está bien o
no yo quiero participar una manera más
activa y ahí es uno les invito a que
sean más más proactivos que se levanten
del asiento en donde estén que no sean
espectadores a tener muy buenos los
próximos años y que busquen la manera
como subiéndose al escenario si son
emprendedores emprendiendo en este en
esta área que está increíble si son
empresarios tratando de entender mejor
si son ejecutivos tratando de traer
estas tecnologías hacia sus empresas si
son académicos estudiando un poquito más
y si son entusiastas simplemente gozando
un poco más el movimiento y acercándose
a quienes lo estamos creando tratando de
crear muchas gracias
[Aplausos]